[Música]
como hemos dicho de los Smith se ha
popularizado Durante los últimos seis
meses y su uso ha sido propulsado a
través de las redes sociales en lo que
se ha convertido en una campaña
gordofoba además de irresponsable Y con
consecuencia su potencialmente dañinas
para el cuerpo para ampliar la discusión
conectamos con paolas abogala de Chávez
nutricionista invitada habitual de
France 24 y doctora en psicología
Gracias por estar con nosotros Paola y
comienzo haciéndole preguntas qué es lo
que hace este medicamento en un cuerpo
que está libre de diabetes Y por qué
seguimos pensando que deshidratación es
lo mismo que pérdida de grasa
Bueno yo creo que hay varias cosas de
los en pico o sea lo primero es que es
realmente un medicamento que muy
fuertemente inhibe el apetito y como lo
decía mar ahorita también hace que el
vaciamiento gástrico sea más lento
entonces en la mayoría de personas lo
que va a producir es que haya una
reducción de las ganas de comer del
hambre en general y que haya una
disminución importante en el consumo
alimentario no y mucho de lo que esto
empieza a generar es también como una
una sensación de satisfacción por
supuesto estamos en una sociedad
gordofóbica donde estamos muy expuestos
a la violencia estética que en últimas a
lo que lleva es que muchas veces las
personas desarrollan trastornos de la
conducta alimentaria derivados de este
uso del medicamento No claro
precisamente una de las preocupaciones
que existen es que una vez se deja de
tomar este medicamento se pierda este
efecto de la reducción del apetito y
además se genere un efecto como de
rebote en las personas que vuelvan a
ganar peso quería preguntarle Cuáles son
los efectos en la salud de que eso
suceda
bueno primero tenemos por supuesto el
White cycling que es este efecto de El
rebote el efecto rebote se ha asociado a
problemas cardiovasculares a muchísimo
más riesgo de diabetes Y por supuesto
también a tener trastornos de la
conducta alimentaria no cuando tú ves
que con un medicamento logras tener un
cuerpo hegemónico al que la sociedad te
ha presionado finalmente pues terminas
también teniendo La decepción de tener
atracones que es uno de los síntomas más
comunes que se generan después de dejar
el medicamento No ya un comer muy
compulsivo que empieza también a generar
mucha angustia en las personas
nuestra relación con la comida Paola y
por eso la hemos citado a usted ese gran
causante de fenómenos como este que
estamos viendo con este medicamento
endocrinólogos describen que bueno se va
la sensación de hambre como bien lo
hemos descrito y Esto hace que la
persona se sienta libre de esa presión
de estar comiendo porque es que
simplemente no no apetece no la comida
pero cuando se suspende el medicamento
esa sensación de hambre vuelve
desbordada y aquí quiero preguntar por
los efectos físicos Como por ejemplo la
piel Sobrante que va a quedar después
sino los efectos psicológicos y
emocionales en una persona que ha
luchado toda su vida Pues con los
alimentos en vez de tener una buena
relación con ellos bueno sí y fíjate que
incluso cuando ya describimos que el
tener la libertad o sea el sentirnos
libres de estar preocupados por la
comida Pues ya hay una relación con la
comida que nuestra sociedad nos está
implantando que es bastante problemática
pero con respecto a quitar el
medicamento justamente los efectos
psicológicos que aparecen son estos no
la angustia de ahora voy a perder Este
cuerpo que he conseguido y que está
mucho más cerca a la normatividad que se
me ha impuesto y hay una gran cantidad
de desesperación por utilizar métodos
Volver al medicamento muchas personas
por ejemplo que llegan a consultarnos a
nosotros Porque están teniendo atracones
han vuelto varias veces al medicamento
para evitar como tener esta re ganancia
de peso y finalmente lo que se genera Es
que la relación con la comida es cada
vez más problemática no como ha habido
una pérdida de peso importante es normal
que el cuerpo quiera recuperar mucho de
lo que ha perdido ahí se generan los
atracones la compulsión alimentaria y
una desesperación muy fuerte alrededor
de del daño en la relación con la comida
también no la gente tiene mucha más
culpa de comer miedo de comer por
recuperar el peso y se sienten culpables
Además porque tenemos la idea de que
comemos Porque nos falta fuerza de
voluntad no y Y eso también genera unos
efectos psicológicos importantes Sí
bueno claramente lo último que
aprendemos es a comer bien o tener una
relación sana con la comida con todas
las consecuencias que eso conlleva yo le
quería preguntar porque este medicamento
también lo están recetando médicos para
adelgazar qué opina de eso y si hay
algunos casos en los que sí podría ser
necesario o Nunca es necesario digamos
que se recete una adelgazamiento para
personas pues que tengan problemas de
salud
Por supuesto que no hoy en día ya
tenemos muchísima evidencia acerca de
cómo es de dañino tanto física como
mentalmente la prescripción de pérdida
de peso en los efectos físicos vemos
todos los del WhatsApp en el efecto Yoyo
como los comentaba ahorita y también el
desarrollo de trastornos de la conducta
alimentaria a nivel mental no y Hay
muchas formas de promover salud que
conocemos hoy en día que no pasan por
promover la pérdida de peso como es
trabajar en hábitos trabajar en sueño
disminuir el horario laboral trabajar en
muchas cosas que realmente pueden
mejorar la calidad de vida y la salud
sin tener que pasar por procedimientos
de pérdida de peso que a largo plazo
pueden generar muchísimos más problemas
de salud Bueno creo que tenemos tiempo
para un par de preguntas más este sábado
es el Día Mundial de la obesidad A cuál
es su opinión doctora sobre que se trate
todavía la obesidad o el peso de una
persona más bien como una enfermedad y
que basados en nuestra corporalidad pues
seamos recetados cuando vamos a una
visita al médico
si es realmente muy preocupante que
sigamos teniendo como Estas ideas
principalmente porque son ideas que
están basadas en estereotipos de raza no
en la diversidad corporal que tenemos
alrededor del mundo y cómo nuestros
cuerpos terminan siendo diferentes
también por todas las herencias
genéticas que se han ido combinando en
nuestro mestizaje entonces creo que
sigue siendo aterrador que para nosotros
la mayor preocupación sea que las
personas pierdan peso cuando además en
paralelo estamos teniendo una epidemia
de trastornos de la conducta alimentaria
que nadie está viendo y que está
haciendo Todavía más preocupante porque
está quitando muchísimo la calidad de
vida de las generaciones que están
creciendo en este momento rápidamente
comentar una última cosa estabas
hablando de estereotipos Qué papel
juegan también los sesgos de género en
esto
muy muy fuertes absolutamente Fíjate que
pese a que los trastornos alimentarios
también han aumentado en todos los
géneros particularmente si los vemos
muchísimo en mujeres y en personas de
todo el espectro lgtbull lgtbq y creo
que ahí hay un espacio importante
también para empezar a reflexionar sobre
Cómo las mujeres seguimos teniendo estas
presiones ya no por términos estéticos
ya disfrazándose en términos de salud
que siguen imponiendo como unos cuerpos
normativos por otro tipo de
justificaciones morales y cuando se
enreda esto con la salud de alguna forma
se vuelve algo como incuestionable no ya
ya podemos decir todos los cuerpos son
lindos pero como no son saludables igual
tenemos que seguir haciendo que la gente
pierda peso Pues bien ese Paola sabogal
Chávez un nutricionista y también
doctora en psicología gracias a usted
a ustedes Gracias igualmente Mara usted
por el acompañamiento y bueno vamos a
hacer una pequeña pausa si le parece y
ya regresamos con más de directo a
América quédense con nosotros
[Música]